un nouveau mandat dans la continuité du
précédent commence au conseil régional
d'île de france valérie pécresse a été
réélue présidente de l'institution
régionale avec un objectif clair pour
les prochaines années une île de france
que je veux rassembler autour d'un grand
dessein celui de faire de notre région
l'une des plus entreprenante et des plus
belles à vivre de france voire même
d'europe lors de cette séance
d'installation 15 vice-présidents ont
été désignés pour la commission
permanente
parmi eux othman nasri avec la
délégation suivante jeunesse promesse
républicaine orientation insertion
professionnelle enseignement supérieur
et recherche
c'est très important pour les emplois de
demain parce que derrière c'est la
formation de la jeunesse
derrière c'est l'attractivité derrière
c'est aussi la relocalisation
industrielle d'un certain nombre
d'activités
l'île de france est aussi la ruralité
nouveau conseiller régional thomas
gourland est aussi président de
rambouillet territoire avec cette
volonté d'agir pour l'intérêt de
l'intercommunalité et de la région notre
président de l'irie pécresse a vraiment
choisi d'avoir une égalité entre
l'urbain et le rural
la présidente avait annoncé dans son
programme tout à 20 minutes dans le
rural donc on va travailler énormément
sur ce point là et on va préserver notre
environnement travailler avec les
agriculteurs
du côté de l'opposition l'union de la
gauche a obtenu 53 sièges
un mot d'ordre la défense de
l'environnement et d'une justice sociale
l'enjeu pour nous c'est rappeler
l'urgence d'agir sur le climat et les
solidarités on l'a vu pendant la crise
sanitaire il ya un enjeu d'inégalités de
lutter contre les inégalités de
l'anticiper
de prévoir la région ile-de-france à
2030 à 2040 pour la génération qui vient
avec respectivement 16 et 15 sièges le
rassemblement national et la république
en marche sont dans une opposition
minoritaire en nous opposant lorsque
nous penserons que les décisions ne sont
pas les bonnes et évidemment en allant
dans le sens des décisions lorsqu'elle
nous paraîtront les bonnes d'être une
opposition
indéterminée sérieuse et pertinente
prochain rendez vous pour les 209
conseillers régionaux une séance prévue
le 21 juillet prochain